hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I'm unboxing something about my
friend Francesca bought me for my
birthday which at this point was quite a
while ago but I've been saving it
because I wanted to open it for you guys
because this is super super cool it's
called fur bow and basically what it is
is I know a lot of you guys have
probably seen next cameras and other
types of dog webcams for this one will
actually give your dog a treat you can
take photos and videos there's a treat
top and there's a to wake up live video
streaming queue way audio barking alert
photos and videos and smart private
let's check it out what I'm most excited
about is being able to give Maddie a
treat well on the way I'm not a huge fan
of talking to him because I don't want
him to get confused and get upset
because he thinks that I'm in a house
and I'm not but I absolutely love the
fact that it is streaming live video oh
wow it looks really good too so here it
is there comes with the fur bow Oh
Maddie's coming in here you know
something for now but a charger and it
looks like this is just a simple
microUSB charger which is fantastic plug
it in download the app that's it so if I
was getting my furball ready so it looks
like it's going to be connecting it to
bluetooth and that's what's happening so
it's it's finding it right now there's a
setup process it says it takes three to
five minutes so I guess I'll just be
right back you got exactly treats so I
don't think he's going to be that into
it at least we'll be able to see if it
works it sounds like a nice little
airtight seal to it so your treats won't
get spoiled
oh my setup a complete that was way less
than three of our minutes it worked it's
not
okay so you can slide a tree okay okay
you do this is lotta tree oh my god it's
through several trees penny will treat
look now you watch ready take a picture
hi baby who do you think cuz you dog I
think you love it even we got some
better treats and now you might like it
the problem is they goes all what any
dog food well this is what I'll do
I'm gonna put a good treat in here okay
Maddie you screwed your grip treat
here's a turn Maddie coming over there
you go honey that's for you he took it
he took it he took it the key here is ah
not using dog food and using delicious
treat good Lulu yes that's my name
that's my name man my 50 you guys have
used your dog's favorite treat space way
too small it shot out like 50 of them
well thank you guys so much for watching
the huge thank you to Francesca for
getting me this incredible device
because this is awesome Chloe to the
description if you guys want to check
this out or get yourself one for your
dog but in meantime I'm gonna go clean
up the dog food mess but I just made
telling you honey
come here baby you know the lemon more
treats commodities
[Music]
Jessica